lo que haremos en este vídeo será
multiplicar los números 352 y 481
llegaremos al resultado de dos formas
distintas sin embargo al final te darás
cuenta de que las ideas importantes son
las mismas lo primero que quiero que
notes es que 352 lo podemos ver como 300
más 50 +2 o déjame escribirlo así es 2
más 50 más 300 si sumas estos tres
números juntos obtienes 352 la misma
idea para 481 al 481 lo podemos ver como
cuatro veces 100 o 400 más 8 veces 10 y
80 más 1 400 es decir cuatro veces 10
más 80 que es lo mismo que 8 veces 10
más 1
seguramente estás familiarizado con esta
forma de escribir los números y
acomodarlos en esta cuadrícula
esencialmente vamos a aplicar la regla
distributiva tomaremos el 2 y lo
multiplicaremos por 400 por 80 y por 1
así que me permite dibujar la cuadrícula
para que todo sea más claro
bien de modo que vamos a multiplicar al
2 por 481 y entonces me queda que todos
por 400 bueno estos 800 2 por 80 eso es
162 por uno es 2 hagamos lo mismo para
el 50 50 x 400 bueno 5 por 4 es 20
entonces es 20 y 30 más 123 20 mil ahora
50 por 80 bueno 5 por 840 más 20 shockey
12 me queda cuatro mil y luego cincuenta
por uno que es 50 bien ahora vamos a
hacer lo mismo para el 300 vamos a
distribuirlo por la suma de estos tres
300 x 400 bueno 3 por 4 12 y 40 123
120.000 perfecto 300 x 83 por 8 24 y 30
por lo tanto es 24.000
y 300 por 1 bueno eso es 300 de lujo
ahora hay que sumar todos estos números
así que sumaremos primero esta fila si
sumo 800 más 160 más 2 bueno eso me da
962 bien aquí tengo bueno 24 mil 50
observan y por acá bajo tengo 144 mil
300 120 mil más 24.000 más 300 144 mil
300 y ahora para obtener el resultado
final simplemente hay que sumar estas
tres cantidades
pero antes de sumarlas quiero ver otra
forma de multiplicar estos dos números a
veces a este segundo algoritmo que voy a
aplicar justo ahorita se le conoce con
el nombre de algoritmo estándar la forma
de hacerlo es tomar al 481 y
multiplicarlo por el 352 en el algoritmo
estándar lo que hacemos es tomar este 2
que está en las unidades y lo
multiplicamos por 481 y dice 2 por unas
2 2 por 8 es 16 así que ponemos el 6 y
llevamos una aunque realmente lo que
estamos haciendo es reagrupando este 1
en las centenas es 10 veces díaz que es
100 y luego 2 x 4 que es 8 que realmente
es 800 más lo que llevábamos 9 que en
realidad es 900 y creo que ya estás
viendo en patrón por aquí este 962 es el
mismo que éste 962
bueno porque realmente lo que hicimos
fue multiplicar el 2 por 1 el 2 por 80 y
el 2 por 400 lo mismo que hicimos aquí y
después lo sumamos 962 esto es lo que
realmente hace el algoritmo estándar
ahora podemos movernos al 5 pero
realmente este 5 es 5 veces 10 y es por
ello que ponemos un cero aquí abajo en
el algoritmo estándar antes de hacer
toda la multiplicación con el 5
recuerdas y dicen 5 por 15 5 por 840 así
que ponemos el cero y reagrupamos el 45
por 420 más 4 es 24 observa 24.050 lo
mismo que teníamos aquí suena lógico
porque estamos tomando el 50 y lo
estamos multiplicando por 481 fue lo
mismo que hicimos a la izquierda ya
puedes imaginar qué va a pasar cuando
tomas este 3 y lo multiplicas por 481
realmente lo que haces es multiplicar
281 por lo que en el algoritmo estándar
como estamos multiplicando por 300
ponemos dos ceros al principio y bueno
cuando digo algoritmo me refiero a un
método para resolver algo si
multiplicamos tres por una es 33 por 824
así que pongo el 4 y llevo 2 3 por 4 es
dos más dos es 14 observa 144 mil
trescientos una vez aquí en el algoritmo
estándar sumamos estas cantidades por lo
tanto sumaremos todo y me quedan dos más
0 +0 bueno eso es 2 y después tengo 65
es once reagrupamos el 11 más 93 es 13
ponemos el 3 y reagrupamos el 11 más 44
eso es 92 más 46 y bajo el 1 ya está
el resultado es 169 mil 312 y cuando
aprendes el algoritmo estándar parece
que todo sale por arte de magia pero
ahora sabes lo que realmente estás
haciendo lo que realmente haces es ir a
cada uno de estos lugares y los
distribuyen es decir lo multiplicas por
400 por 80 y por 1 y lo sumas después
tomas el siguiente número que realmente
es 50 y lo multiplicas por 400 más 80
más uno y después 300 y lo multiplicas
por 400 más 81 de la misma manera como
lo hicimos aquí eso es todo por este
vídeo hasta la próxima